like he might not have any other option  right who would pick then do you need to  look at your choices and how you ended  up with that man yeah or is it that some  some guys will end up with females like  it's easier for them because they like  control or power so if you look at a lot  of relationships that are like  unfortunately like abusive in whatever  way whether that's mentally or  physically is so control element where  they'll go with women who are more  vulnerable who don't have that  confidence who are insecure because it's  easier for them to and bigger girls men  like you know we're bigger girls get  what they want out of those women and